Ngay ai mới tháng 5 trong khốn cầu chuyên thầm chính thuy trứng Quốc,
tổng thống ngay là đi miếp u jin và trụ tịch trứng Quốc tập cầm mình đã ký và thông qua tuyên bố trông
về thế lập trực thế dời đà cờ và quan hệ của tầy triệu mới.
Theo ăn tình tháng 3, anh ở đồ lùa đứa tiêm,
phân kinh nhấn mạnh hệ thông quan hệ của tầy đáng trẻ qua quá trình chuyên đủ sâu sách,
hướng tớm một trở từ đà trường tâm, bối xe hình khánh các cơ trễ hợp tăng mởi xe cơ cơ xe.
Tế bối trung cho sang những nỗ lực đường phân ăn đặt lửa íc,
hoặc thêm thêm vào công việc nội bộ của cố giả khác,
là không phù hợp bối xu thay và trình hình này đồng thời gian hỏi tôn trọng trực quyền và bình đậm giữa các cố giả.
Ngà bà trung Quốc hình định càng kế thúc đầy một đệ thống quan trị tăng cầu cơ bằng và hợp li hơn.
Dự chien các quên tắc như ăn định công để trở cánh, hợp tắc tình có lợi,
tôn trọng đà sản thân mình và giám trụ hả quan hệ của tầy.
Hãy đến cụng những mạnh phá trọng măng tình xe dựa của nha và trung Quốc,
cho biến dưới chiếc các bạn của lực quan cầu và o định trực tự cuối tế.
Theo chờ lý tổng thống Ngà Jury Yuzhacho,
bân kẹn gái bống bài trang này,
đình hướng hợp tắc sòng phương và quan điểm chung,
về nhiều bánh đề quan cầu quan trọng.